herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen hallo
deutschland woche und zu unserem corona
kompakt schön dass sie mit dabei sind
kurz vor dem heutigen staates teil
lockdown wollten es viele noch mal
wissen
noch ein einziges mal in die
lieblingskneipe oder ins restaurant um
die ecke
denn jetzt geht das ja nicht mehr der
laden voll die stimmung getrübt
im traditionshaus zur post in wolnzach
landkreis pfaffenhofen war der antrag am
wochenende noch einmal groß zuletzt
waren nur noch wenige gäste in das
restaurant von benjamin stuhlmiller
gekommen
große feiern ausgefallen trotz hygiene
konzept wir tun ja alles damit wir
einfach unseren job machen dürfen
und deswegen verstehe ich nicht dass
ausgerechnet wir zu spüren
während dem frühjahr das verständnis für
die maßnahmen der politik hier noch groß
war sieht das heute anders aus immer
wieder mehr investiert trennwände
bestellt und so weiter und so fort und
völlig unbegreiflich
es gibt immer ein paar schwarze schafe
klar was man aus hamburg gehört oder
sonst woher aber das ist nicht die regel
unverständnis auch unter den gästen den
zuständen wie in hamburg oder berlin das
natürlich anders optimist möglich selber
nennt ist möglich oder hermann oder
liest man vielleicht auch bei uns am
rand lassen
es ist völlig falsche entscheidung ganz
berlin ablassen private feiern stunden
ganz so übersichtlich und diszipliniert
ging es in nordrhein westfalen nicht zu
[Musik]
voll voller düsseldorf samstagabend die
altstadt
polizei und ordnungsamt kontrollieren
die stimmung überwiegend ausgelassen bis
aggressiv bußgelder gegen bar betreiber
und gäste werden fällig 2500 für den
betreiber 250 pro gast wie hier zum
beispiel zivile kräfte haben wir
festgestellt dass wir einen barbetrieb
war oder auch livemusik gespielt worden
ist als die kollegen den betrieb
betreten haben sind viele personen aus
dem notausgang geflohen waren nur acht
personen eingetragen
und ja da die sehr uneinsichtig waren
hier mussten dann auch noch weitere
kräfte in zum zuhören aufbruchstimmung
auf sylt saison zu ende
eine insel macht dicht dank corona
abbauen aufräumen abreise touristen
müssen aufs festland zurück die
gefühlslage traurig
naja wir müssen da durch wir hoffen dass
es nächstes jahr besser ist aber bis
freitag muss die insel er sein
die müsste gefühle weil mir alles getan
haben um einfach die ausbreitung von dem
virus zu verhindern
ich glaube das kann wieder die politik
nur vier können das richtig einschätzen
ob das jetzt den gewünschten erfolg hat
aber irgendwo müssen wir jetzt was tun
inselbewohner dagegen scheinen gar nicht
so unglücklich zu sein über die
bevorstehenden wochen
wir sind froh dass eigentlich zu gut
dass die touristen nach hause fahren
müssen damit jetzt krone nicht auf die
insel kommt wir haben den ersten block
darauf den soll ja auch mitgemacht und
das war mit die schönste zeit hier im
märz wenn man ist man jetzt dreimal am
tag zum strand runter gegangen es war
nicht viele leute hier man hat viele
freunde treffen können die eigentlich
sonst die ganze zeit rund um die ohren
arbeiten sind von sylt nach hamburg die
reeperbahn im ruhemodus tote hose kurz
vor 23 uhr am sonntagabend die
strahlenden neonlichter werden abgedreht
die große freiheit vorübergehend
ausgesetzt
und jetzt das große bangen und hoffen
auf die dezemberzahlen
wenn es noch bis april mai dauert dann
würde ich würde die ganze situation für
die menschen zum verkraften
da die 200 so würde ich jetzt auf gar
keinen fall auch machen weil das einfach
unverantwortlich ist wir halten uns halt
dran das ist nämlich wieder vorbeigeht
und das sollten genau prüfen
es wäre gut vermutlich ist das zurzeit
die beste strategie elisabeth raffauf
ist psychologin und uns jetzt
zugeschaltet sie weiß was der neue teil
lockdown mit unserer psyche macht und
wie man sich jetzt gut um sich selbst
kümmern kann frau rausch auf was macht
uns denn psychisch so schwer in diesem
teil lockdown ja hallo frau schock wir
haben das ja gerade schon so ein
bisschen gehört also viele menschen sind
irgendwie auch frustriert oder auch
resigniert weil sie so das gefühl haben
jetzt haben wir alles getan wir haben
uns sonne mühe gegeben und jetzt soll
das irgendwie gar nichts nützen und
manche fühlen sich natürlich auch
ohnmächtig und haben das gefühl wir
wollen was tun und wir können aber
nichts tun und natürlich was wir auch
gehört haben es gibt natürlich auch wut
und es gibt auch angst nämlich angst
weil die fallzahlen steigen und weil die
belegung der betten steigen also es ist
so ein ziemlicher cocktail von gefühlen
und dann natürlich die frage was können
wir machen ja gibt es denn
psychologische strategien wie schafft
man es mit gesundem gemüt durch diesen
november ja das wichtigste ist dass man
sich erst mal klar macht der feind ist
außen also nicht mein mann ist plötzlich
der feind oder die politiker sondern das
virus ist der feind also wir sind
eigentlich noch freunde auch wenn wir
abstand voneinander halten müssen und
für uns ist es absolut wichtig dass wir
zusammenhalten und natürlich im privaten
und auch im beruflichen dass wir gucken
wie können wir jetzt kreative lösungen
finden was können wir anders machen wie
können wir mit dieser schwierigen
situation umgehen und wenn wir
dass alle zusammen machen haben wir die
größten chancen das auch zu schaffen und
für manche leute ist es auch gut zu
gucken wie habe ich dann den letzten
lockdown geschafft dieser ist ja so ein
bisschen lockdown leid was kann ich
sozusagen an strategien auch mit rüber
retten
und wie können wir uns die meisten
menschen haben ja so dieses gefühl das
schlimmste ist eigentlich dass wir uns
sozial nicht mehr so gut begegnen können
und wie können wir trotzdem weiter gut
kontakt halten zu unseren freunden
das ist für viele ganz ganz wichtig sie
haben eben den vergangenen lockdown
schon angesprochen welche
psychologischen massen folgen bringt der
mit sich kann man da schon was zu sagen
ja es gibt ja auch schon studien zum
beispiel von der hamburger universität
das vor allem auch bei kindern und
jugendlichen das man schon feststellen
kann dass es mehr ängste gibt auch mehr
traurigkeit konzentrationsstörungen
schlafstörungen also das im alltag die
kinder und jugendlichen wirklich
gelitten haben und die erwachsenen
natürlich auch und deshalb ist es ja
auch gut dass wir im moment die
situation haben dass die schulen und die
kitas offen sind und dass so viel
normalität oder so viel struktur auch
wie möglich für die kinder und
jugendlichen da ist und das entlastet
natürlich auch die eltern sehr gut
vielen dank ihr diese betraf auch für
diese informationen und heute sehen sie
hier bei uns auch ein zdf spezial corona
krise deutschland fährt runter um 19 uhr
julia und axel bode hatten sich seit
wochen auf die wiedereröffnung ihres
restaurants gefreut sie haben stammgäste
eingeladen und auch ordentlich werbung
gemacht heute wollten sie wieder
aufmachen und jetzt das das team am
restaurant mit dem ball hat es schwer in
diesem jahr erst corona lockdown im
frühjahr dann ein wasserschaden acht
wochen baustelle und jetzt wieder nichts
wir haben wirklich alles auf dieses
tolle datum zweiter elfter 20
ausgerichtet um hier wieder voll
durchzustarten in der küche ist nach der
lockdown ankündigung nicht mehr viel
passiert die letten der leitung lag
hinter dieser wand
ja das hat sie sich erst nach einer
etwas kleineren sache angefühlt
blicken wir mal und dann wird es wieder
zugemacht aber die feuchtigkeit war
schon wirklich es ist ein sehr altes
haus unseres tief ins mauerwerk
eingedrungen
die bodes haben investiert neuer
küchenchef neuer restaurantleiter die
gesamte belegschaft geht jetzt zum
zweiten mal in diesem jahr in kurzarbeit
mit gemischten gefühlen
das ist bitter dass mir einfallen würde
gerade so in den letzten tagen wurde die
vorbereitungen kamen sie auf die
zielgerade und wir waren schon echt
feuer und flamme dafür wieder zu öffnen
bis zu 75 prozent staatliche
ausgleichszahlungen helfen natürlich die
restaurantinhaber sehen ihre branche
aber ungerechtfertigt in die pflicht
genommen
ich kann nur dafür plädieren und hoffe
dass das auch alles gehalten wird was
man jetzt verspricht lockdown
wasserschaden lockdown alle hoffen jetzt
dass sie zum weihnachtsgeschäft öffnen
dürfen
und natürlich wissen wir dass wir uns
die hände gründlich waschen sollten und
den mund nasen schutz tragen aber wo
lauert die ansteckungsgefahren noch auf
welchen alltagsgegenständen zum beispiel
auf dem fahrstuhl knopf der türklinke
oder dem handy
das corona virus bestimmt immer noch
einen großen teil unseres täglichen
lebens steigende infektionszahlen
verunsichern uns wo genau lauern
gefahren im alltag und wie schützen wir
uns am besten
professor knobloch ist virologe am
uniklinikum in hamburg eppendorf
ihn haben wir gefragt wie groß die
gefahr einer ansteckung in bestimmten
situationen sein kann zb bei der
handynutzung wir fassen es häufig mit
ungewaschenen händen an und legen es auf
den unterschiedlichsten flächen ab aber
kann das handy auch eine gefahr
darstellen wenn es um eine ansteckung
mit dem corona virus geht wir haben
tatsächlich auch das erbmaterial auf
handys von betroffenen patienten
nachweisen können allerdings auch hier
wieder nicht an züchten können aber man
muss sagen wenn ich selber infiziert bin
kann ich mich ja nicht erneut
implizieren das heißt auf einem handy
finden wir immer die flora der person
selbst
aber die ist ungefährlich weil es meine
eigene rachen flora ist und auch nicht
gefährlich ist wenn ich meine eigene
rachen flora zurück in maine brachen
kommt und beim einkaufen ohne maske darf
nirgendwo in deutschland ein geschäft
betreten werden
sie soll uns und andere vor einer
infektion schützen
doch wie ist es mit den eingekauften
waren schließlich können wir davon
ausgehen dass sie von mehreren personen
vor uns schon angefasst wurden also im
wesentlichen ist es wichtig wenn man
nach hause kommt weil man auch auf dem
nachhauseweg ja noch ganz viele sachen
anfassen kann tatsächlich sich die hände
zu waschen wenn ich natürlich
unmittelbar danach in mein eigenes auto
steige und dann auch keine
unterschiedlichen dinge mehr anfassen
kann nicht möglicherweise auch vor ort
mir noch die hände wasche eine
übertragung durch kontaminierte
oberflächen sei möglich spiele aber im
vergleich zu einer übertragung durch
tröpfchen oder ihre sohlen eine
untergeordnete rolle
wer länger draußen unterwegs ist kommt
kaum drumherum mal ein öffentliches wc
zu benutzen
wie groß ist die gefahr einer ansteckung
hier können in den ausscheidungen viren
enthalten sein und überleben dieser eine
gewisse zeit auf verschiedenen
oberflächen
also wir wissen dass die viren mit dem
stuhl ausgeschieden werden können oder
zumindest die das erbgut des virus dort
nachweisbar ist wahrscheinlich ist es
aber kein infektiöses virus das heißt es
wäre gefährlich mit drei personen eine
kabine zu nutzen weil man dann wieder
sehr engen kontakt ist aber in einer die
einzel nutzung einer kabine ist mit
allem was wir wissen nicht gefährlich
und was ist mit uran im urin finden wir
keine viren nur bei schwerstkranken
menschen kann es theoretisch wenn die
werde vollständig versagt und das virus
im ganzen körper verbreitet es in den
urin übertreten
aber wer eine öffentliche toilette
besuchen kann ist sicherlich nicht so
schwer krank dass man dort das virus im
urin nachweisen entgegen
eine weitere alltagssituation ist die
paketannahme die deutsche post zeigt in
diesem informations video wie eine
optimale paket übergabe aussieht der
postbote legt das paket vor der tür ab
und hält ausreichend abstand zum
empfänger kann die annahme eines pakets
trotzdem riskant sein
auch hier ist es maximal das gespräch
mit dem boden nicht die oberfläche des
pakets die gefährliche
auch wenn man sich vornimmt draußen so
wenig wie möglich anzupassen
manchmal kommt es eben doch vor dass wir
gegenstände und oberflächen berühren
der fahrstuhl knopf türklinke oder der
haltegriff im bus wie hoch das tier das
ansteckungsrisiko auch hier müsste
relativ kurz vorher eine person in die
hand geniest oder gehustet haben das ist
ja durch die pflicht eine maske zu
tragen extremst unwahrscheinlich dass
jemand eine stark kontaminierte hand hat
und ich musste in dem sehr kurzen
zeitlichen abstand exakt an dieselbe
stelle fassen und dann soviel virus
aufnehmen dass ich es mir in die
schleimhäute von augen oder mund
transferieren
es ist auch hier eine theoretisch
mögliche übertragung die aber keine
rolle spielt gefährlich so der experte
wird es vor allem dann wenn wir uns ohne
abstand mit anderen unterhalten oder zu
viele menschen in einem schlecht
gelüfteten raum sind solche situationen
gilt es zu vermeiden und dafür ist jeder
von uns selbst verantwortlich ja so ist
es und wenn sie wissen wollen wie die
lage in ihrem wohnort ist können sie das
auch auf zdf de nachlesen
da gibt es alle aktuellen zahlen in
übersichtlichen grafiken und das war
unser corona kompakt